Neal: The scene is indelibly imprinted
on anyone who's been to college:
row after row of students gazing down
as a professor or a TA drones on
about chemical bonds or
the Byzantine Empire.
The long lecture is widely accepted
as an economical and effective way
to educate large groups of students,
but in a piece for Time Magazine,
Salman Khan argues that even
the most brilliant speaker
and the most compelling subject
won't hold students' attention
for more than 18 minutes.
So, call and tell us about
the lecture you remember best;
800-989-8255; email us talk@npr.org.
You could also join the
conversation on our website,
that's at npr.org, click
on "Talk of the Nation."
Salman Khan is founder
of the Khan Academy,
author of "The One World
Schoolhouse: Education Reimagined,"
and joins us now from his
studio in Stanford, California.
Nice to have you with us today.
Salman: Great to be here.
Neal: What is it that makes
those lectures so boring?
Salman: (chuckles) Well, I think all of us
could answer that in a very anecdotal way,
but what I think a lot
of people don't realize
is that there's actually
been research in this base,
to study the lecture,
and it's pretty decisive,
it's never been really contradicted,
that people can pay attention
for about 10-18 minutes,
after which they start zoning out.
Then they can kind of re-check
in for about 10 minutes,
then they zone out for an
even longer period of time,
and that keeps going on.
Studies have shown that when
you do lecture at someone,
that you actually retain some
of the early information,
you retain very little of
the latter information.
Just as you described,
a lot of the reason why
we do it this way is really logistics;
logistics coming from a
reality where we didn't have
any other technologies to
deliver the information,
so we, for the most part,
in colleges and K through 12
around the world, we still
have a bunch of students
sitting there for 60-90
minutes being lectured at.
Neal: That vacillating
attention span you talk about,
you could miss out on
entire pharaonic dynasties.
Salman: (laughs) No, no,
that's exactly right.
It hasn't gone completely unrecognized.
There have been attempts
to address this issue.
I talk about it in the book,
that there have been professors
that try to do these change-ups,
try to ask questions,
try to do little group
things every 10 or 15 minutes
to address this issue,
but what I point out is that
that's a bit of a half-way fix.
What we really should think
is well, is this class time,
this time that all these
human beings get together,
is lecture even the best use of that?
Neal: Well, you've got to convey a certain
amount of information
to, certainly in the case
of college introduction
courses, a whole bunch
of people at the same time.
Salman. That's right, and
200 years ago I probably
couldn't have come up with
a better way of doing that.
Now we have very on-demand
ways to access media,
obviously things like YouTube,
obviously things like Khan
Academy what I work on,
but there's other efforts.
There's EdEx that MIT
and Harvard are doing.
A lot of med schools have actually
been doing this for a little while,
where students are getting
the information delivery,
the lecture, at their own time and pace.
There are benefits to that
because you can pause.
If there's a word you don't understand,
you could look it up on the internet.
You can go ask a friend.
If you forgot a little bit
of your review material
from a couple of years ago,
no need to be embarrassed
and raise your hand in the middle of class
and stop everyone's learning.
You can go review that material,
and you don't have to take notes
because it's always there.
Then when you go to class time,
you can use that for
something more valuable
like a conversation or a project
or some type of peer-to-peer learning.
Neal: But isn't it also the
student's responsibility
to absorb some of this knowledge?
Salman: It is, it is, and
it's always going to be
the student's responsibility.
In fact, I think that's
why lecture misses,
is that at the end of the
day, learning is something
that the student has to decide to do.
At the university level, especially,
I've always said it would
be interesting to administer
a final exam 2 days
before students thought
that they were going to get the final exam
and see what the delta is.
You'll see that very
little of the learning,
or at least as measured by the final exam,
occurs in the first 90% of the class.
It's really the last 2-3
days before the exam,
students are cramming
and teaching each other
and that's what's really
moving the dial on their exams.
Neal: I wonder, you said
you don't have to take notes
if you can have electronic
copies of the lectures,
digital copies that you
can go back and refer to.
Doesn't the act of taking
notes help you learn?
Salman: The act of doing
anything does help you learn.
Fundamentally, if you
are passive in anything
you're probably not that engaged.
I think a lot of students do take notes
literally just to stay awake,
literally to be engaged.
A lot of students say they
don't use the notes later on,
it's just really to somewhat stay engaged.
That's the whole point.
If we want students to stay engaged,
going through this
exercise of taking notes
while listening to a lecture,
and oftentimes not being able to listen
because they're taking notes,
let's just make it more active.
Instead of doing these change-ups
every 10 or 15 minutes,
let's make the whole classroom change-ups.
Let's make the whole classroom
students teaching each other,
students having a
conversation with each other.
The one thing I point
out a lot in the book is
we talk about this human
experience of education,
but when students are
sitting in a classroom
and there's someone lecturing at them,
maybe they're taking notes,
you're in a room with 30,
maybe 300 other people
at the college level,
that's a very dehumanizing experience.
I've sat in classes for the whole semester
and I didn't know 98% of those people,
I didn't know their names.
What we're really advocating,
and we're starting to see in a
lot of schools and universities,
is let's have those 300 people
interact with each other.
Instead of having a study
group just the last 3 days
before the exam, why don't we
have it for the whole semester?
Neal: A study group with 300 people;
that's not a class, it's a potential riot.
Salman: (laughs) No, no, that's right.
I think that's where
technology comes in, again.
One, it can help deliver
some of the information
that lectures used to do;
but now you can also coordinate.
You can see where students
are in their skill levels,
you can pair them up,
you can give diagnostics to the teacher.
Some people say, "Well, students might not
"listen to lecture if
it's happening at home."
Before they had homework
that could have been checked.
What I point out, and most
people agree with this,
is that the homework,
or the problem solving,
is where the learning is happening.
If students are going to check out
of one of the two things, I would say
make sure it's not the problem solving.
Neal: Going back to your
days as a student, though,
are there lectures that you
remember particularly vividly?
Salman: (chuckles) I
talk a lot in the book,
my own experience in
undergrad, I talk about,
I was a bit of a chronic class skipper.
sometimes out of laziness,
but for the most part it
was just out of finding
the most productive use of my time.
I discovered there was this whole world,
this was at MIT,
of people who never went to class
and would use that time to
do problem solving instead.
For the most part, the
ones that were memorable
were the ones where there
was a shared experience.
There were some great orators,
some great lecturers that were inspiring,
but it was good for moments.
It wasn't great when you were trying
to dig deep into something,
when you might be a little bit lost
and you want to catch up but
the class is going at a pace,
you might be a little bit bored,
you might know the material already.
I think the shared experience of a lecture
is great for inspirational things.
It's great for things
that aren't super deep
in terms of the substantive nature.
I think those type of things can happen
on-demand at your own pace,
then class time is all
about problem solving.
Neal: We're talking with Salman Khan,
founder of the Khan Academy,
a non-profit that creates
online educational videos.
He's the author of
"The One World Schoolhouse:
Education Reimagined."
We want to hear today from you
about the college lecture
you vividly remember,
800-989-8255, email talk@npr.org.
Benjamin's on the line
with us from Fort Wayne.
Benjamin: Hi there.
Neal: Hi.
Benjamin: What I remember
out of all the lectures
that I've had in college
is from my sociology class.
Robert Pettit, he's a
great sociology teacher,
he was using visuals
along with his speech,
and he was teaching us about
socially constructed realities.
Basically, he was petting an
invisible cat on his desk.
Neal: (laughs)
Benjamin: With saying, if we all believe
there was a cat here, then
therefore it does exist.
It was really interesting.
I've found that incorporating
visuals with speaking
made it easier to remember,
more likely to remember.
Neal: Clearly you remember that one.
How long ago was that?
Benjamin: That was, I
would say, 2 years ago.
Neal: That's not all that long ago.
Benjamin: No, not at all.
Neal: All right, thanks very
much for the phone call.
Appreciate it.
Benjamin: Thank you.
Neal: So even some simple
devices, acting out
and some visuals, Salman
Khan, can help somewhat.
Salman: It sounds like that
was a great instructor,
a great lecturer.
What I would say is that actually
he should share those skills,
and it sounds like he was
humorous and all the rest,
that instructor should make videos,
put them online.
His students could access them.
Then when they go class,
they can actually have
that debate about whether,
if everyone believes the cat is there,
whether it really is there.
Neal: Let's see if we go to James.
James is with us from
Montrose in Colorado.
James: Hi Neal.
Neal: Hi.
James: I just wanted to share
really my most memorable
and this little instance
was the only memory
that I have of the entire
semester in this class.
Neal: (chuckles)
James: Physical geography,
where my professor
was teaching for the first
time in America from China.
Nobody could understand a word she said
until she made one comment
about how she recently
arrived in American and a
friend called her from China
and she's trying to describe
the Earth's rotation
around the sun and how days
and nights are different
on different sides of the planet,
and her friend says,
"Hi, how are you doing?"
She said, "Well, how in the
hell do you think I'm doing?
"It's 3 in the morning, I'm sleeping."
That was the only bit
that me and probably 175
other students caught
for 3-1/2 plus months.
Neal: (laughs)
Neal: How'd you do on the course?
James: That was about 12-1/2 years ago.
I want to say I did pretty well.
I enjoyed the class, but honestly,
I can't remember a lick of it.
Neal: I guess, Salman Khan,
thanks very much for the call, James,
that makes your point.
Salman: Yeah, that's exactly.
Most of us can't remember
actually the courses we took,
and I'm not that far out of college,
much less the actual
content of a lot of it.
Even when you were there,
running up to the final exam,
this is why there are so
many students cramming,
is that they've learned very little.
They've gone through the motions.
They feel like they're paying tuition.
It's part of the, I guess the
ceremony of going to college,
of showing up at these lectures
because that seems to be
what everyone else is doing.
But I've actually found that the students
that are most productive are the ones
that use that time to
go do something else.
Neal: Email from Alan in Augusta, Georgia.
"Of thousands of lectures I've enjoyed,
"the best is no doubt Jack Pettigrew's
"'Love is a Plastic State.'
"I heard this as a student at his
"neurophysiology class in Caltech in 1975,
"but he delivered it elsewhere as well.
"The point was to discuss
neuronal plasticity,
"how our brains change,
"and he illustrated it
with numerous anecdotes
"including how his brother-in-law
"lost his fear of a
deadly snake while high.
"Jack really illuminated the subject,
"the impact of evolution on brain states."
We're talking with Salman
Khan about lectures
and re-imagining them.
You're listening to Talk of
the Nation from NPR News.
Let's go next to Richard.
Richard is with us from
Sioux City in Iowa.
Richard: Hi, hello everybody.
Nice program.
Neal: Thank you.
Richard: Thanks for having me on.
I teach mindfulness and I
was in a mindfulness course
at University of Missouri
quite a few years ago,
a graduate-level course.
The first lecture about mindfulness was,
actually started with eating
a raisin and where we,
the raisins were passed out.
The idea is we're going
to focus our attention
on all of the sensuous
aspects of the raisin
before we even taste it,
before we put it in our mouth.
Mindfulness, as you may
know, is, of course,
the entire process of controlling
your attentional awareness.
The intent of mindfulness
is that we train our minds
so that they don't drift away
or drift forward or drift back,
and we do have more
disciplined thinking processes.
Neal: Did it worked after 18
minutes or so with the raisin?
Richard: (laughs) Yeah.
I'd say with that course it really did
because it was an 8-week course
and it absolutely helps to discipline,
again, your attentional awareness.
Where is your attention
at this very moment?
Is it where it should be or not?
As a person who now prepares and teaches
those programs for a couple of schools,
I can tell you it does work.
It may be something that
would be of interest
or that your guests may already be,
of which they may already be aware.
Neal: Salman Khan, are
you aware of mindfulness?
Salman: I think that example,
the reason why it was so memorable
is because the students
were doing something.
They were observing the raisin.
They were given an activity to do.
They weren't just being lectured at.
What I'm saying is that
lecture's invaluable.
People have given some examples of some
very memorable lectures they had.
It's just that is that the best use
of when humans get together?
A lot of these very entertaining,
very inspiring lectures ...
I'm coming here as someone who's made
3,000 lectures on YouTube.
I'm not saying that they're not valuable,
I'm just saying that they
could maybe be best used
when you're not in the classroom.
In the classroom, you
should do things like that,
expose people to new experiences,
make them think about it,
have a two-way conversation.
Richard: I agree because
in teaching mindfulness,
I do have a didactic and
then an experiential portion.
During the didactic portions
I do try to limit it
to 12 minutes or so
because I know what happens
and people don't pay attention.
Neal: Interesting.
Thanks very much for the call, Richard.
Richard: Thank you.
Neal: That amount of
time, is that time span,
that ability to focus for 10-18 minutes,
does that cover other aspects
of interaction as well?
Salman: You know, I haven't
seen studies on that,
but I would believe that
that's probably the case.
Even in our organization,
we're not-for-profit,
but there's 36 people who work with me,
we kind of eat our own dog food.
We say, look, if we ever have a meeting,
no one should be talking
for more than 3 minutes.
If you're talking for more than 3 minutes,
it's a lecture, make a video,
Neal: (laughs)
and people can ask you
questions when we get together.
Neal: So you have to do that as well.
Then the space of these
interactive meetings,
presumably people could
concentrate a little longer.
Salman: We've all had
hours-long conversations
and enjoyed ourselves.
That's actually where we learned a lot.
A lot of what we learn from is from
conversations with other people
That, obviously, can go on well beyond
10 minutes or even an hour
because you are actively engaged,
your brain is actively processing
and thinking of new things.
Neal: Let's see, we
get one more caller in.
This is Jennifer.
Jennifer's on the line
with us from Orange County.
Jennifer: Hello.
Neal: Hi Jennifer.
Jennifer. Hi.
I had a Disability and Society class,
actually it was a psychology class,
in undergrad and I really
remember very little
from undergraduate school.
There was a guest speaker
who had cerebral palsy.
It was my first experience
really hearing from a person
who had cerebral palsy.
Before that, I had no
idea that their brains
functioned exactly the same way
that a normal person's functions,
it was just their muscles and their bodies
didn't work the same
and they weren't able to
communicate the same way.
Being in that room,
there was probably over
200 people in that lecture,
but the professor did such an amazing job
of bringing people in
and engaging the class
and changing perspectives.
Another thing that she did is she had us,
in the midst of our lecture,
walk around campus and picture
ourselves in a wheelchair,
and then come back to the room
and talk about what that
might have been like
if we actually were in a wheelchair
and how we would have gotten around.
Neal: So experiencing something,
as well as just being lectured to.
Jennifer, thanks very much for your time.
Jennifer: Thank you.
Neal: One last email.
This from Janice in Scottsdale.
"A professor of philosophy
at Eisenhower College
"in Seneca Falls, New York
"was assigned the day's
world studies lecture
"to our sophomore class,
approximately 100 students.
"The topic was Zen Buddhism.
"He went up to the podium
"and stood there in
complete and utter silence,
"looking at us for 50 minutes."
Salman Khan, thanks very much
for your time today, too.
Salman: Thanks for having me.
Neal: It's the Talk of
the Nation from NPR News.